House of the Dragon, the Game of Thrones prequel
series that airs in 2022 on HBO, has been
filming for months now and you can expect
to see the live-action trailer with most of
the characters very soon.
In fact, a very limited amount of people that
mostly includes the press have already seen
it and they all liked it.
All of you will see it soon as well, I promise.
But before that, let me introduce you to the
main characters of the show.
As most of you already know, House of the
Dragon, is based on George R.R. Martin’s
Targaryen history book, Fire And Blood, that
begins its tale with the legendary Aegon the
Conqueror, creator of the Iron Throne, and
goes all the way up to the Targaryen civil
war that nearly destroyed House Targaryen,
the Dance of the Dragons.
The Fire And Blood part 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, war with Dorne and go all the
way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
This particular show, House of the Dragon,
will cover the Dance of the Dragons.
If you are more interested in other time periods,
do not worry because HBO is working on a total
of 6 Game of Thrones prequel shows.
Anyways, back to our main characters of the
House of the Dragon.
Since the key event of the show is the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which is also the key event in the history
of House Targaryen, as you might have guessed
it, Targaryens are mostly the main characters.
Season 1 of House of the Dragon will see a
build-up towards the Dance of the Dragons.
The show will not jump straight into the Targaryen
civil war, it will start with a prelude, with
King Viserys l sitting on the Iron Throne,
and with a huge rivalry between his children.
On one side we have King Viserys' daughter
and chosen heir, Rhaenyra, supported by her
father's cousin, Rhaenys Targaryen slash Velaryon,
her uncle Daemon Targaryen and Corlys Velaryon,
the Sea Snake, among many more.
On the other hand we have Rhaenyra's younger
half-sibling Aegon Targaryen supported by
his mother, Queen Alicent Hightower, his grandfather,
Otto Hightower who is the Hand of the King
and Ser Criston Cole, who is the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard.
All the names I just mentioned will be the
main characters in season 1 of the House of
the Dragon.
In the first few episodes,the animosity at
the court between Rhaenyra's supporters and
Aegon's supporters will also be established.
King Viserys I Targaryen is the one who sits
on the Iron Throne at the beginning of the
series, he is the fifth Targaryen king to
sit on the Iron Throne.
Viserys is a dragon rider who rode the legendary
Balerion the Black Dread, until the dragon
died of old age.
Viserys has a brother, Daemon Targaryen, the
most controversial man of his lifetime, who
at this point of the series is the King of
the Stepstones and the Narrow Sea.
Wielding Valyrian steel blade Dark Sister,
Daemon is considered by many to be the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He's the best fighter, he is the best general
and commander and he will prove everyone right
in the upcoming war.
But back to King Viserys.
Viserys had three children by his first queen,
Aemma Arryn, but only one, Princess Rhaenyra,
survived to adulthood.
Lacking a son to succeed him, Viserys began
to train Rhaenyra to be his heir, named her
his heir and Rhaenyra soon acquired the support
of hundreds of lords and landed knights.
The king remarried in 106 AC, this time to
Alicent Hightower, and had four more children:
Aegon, Helaena, Aemond, and Daeron.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of Viserys's
marriage to Alicent.
During the opening feast, Queen Alicent wore
a green gown, while Princess Rhaenyra dressed
in red and black of House Targaryen.
Note was taken, and soon all of Rhaenyra's
supporters started wearing black clothing,
while all of Alicent's followers started wearing
green.
Over time, the popular names applied to both
factions were inspired by the colors they
wore: Rhaenyra's supporters were called "the
Blacks", and Aegon II's supporters were called
"the Greens".
Viserys I strengthened Rhaenyra's place in
the succession by marrying her in 114 AC to
the son of the Sea Snake, Ser Laenor Velaryon
- who himself had Targaryen blood through
his mother, Princess Rhaenys.
Rhaenyra gave birth to three sons—Jacaerys,
Lucerys, and Joffrey Velaryon—during her
marriage, although there were rumors that
the father of those princes was not Laenor,
but Ser Harwin Strong.
One way or the other, House Velaryon plays
a huge role since the very beginning of the
show and will play a huge role up until the
end.
The most famous and strongest Velaryion to
ever live is also one of the main characters
in the upcoming House of the Dragon show – Corlys
Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake.
He's a fabled Lord of the Tides during Targaryen
civil war, Master of Driftmark, and the head
of House Velaryon that’s been a loyal ally
to the Targaryens since Aegon the Conqueror.
During the Conquest, it was Velaryon ships
that carried Aegon’s soldiers across Blackwater
Bay, and later formed the greater part of
the royal fleet.
Going even further back into history, House
Velaryon, much like House Targaryen, is from
Valyria.
He is the husband of another main character,
Princess Rhaenys Targaryen, the Queen-Who-Never-Was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, he even becomes
the Hand to Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen who is
his niece and daughter-in-law.
After Laenor was executed in Spicetown in
120 AC, Rhaenyra married the other main character,
her uncle, infamous Rogue Prince, Prince Daemon
Targaryen, younger brother to Viserys I.
Her sons by him are Aegon the Younger—called
so to distinguish him from his uncle, Alicent's
Aegon, who on occasion is called Aegon the
Elder—and Viserys.
The relationship between Rhaenyra and Alicent
declined early in Alicent's marriage to Viserys,
since both ladies had been trying to be the
realm's first lady, and there could only be
one.
Alicent's father, Ser Otto Hightower, had
also disliked Rhaenyra's second husband, Prince
Daemon, since the beginning of Viserys's reign.
So up until this point of season 1, we will
learn much and more about these characters,
their intentions and their loyalties.The war
begins towards the end of season 1 when our
first main character, King Viserys dies and
his children, the other two main characters,
Rhaenyra and Aegon, each proclaim themselves
the rightful heir to the throne, and the other
six main characters rally between one or the
other.
For Rhaenyra it's her husband Daemon Targaryen,
her own blood Rhaenys and her husband Corlys
the Sea Snake Velaryon.
Again, there's many more who support Rhaenyra,
namely House Arryn and House Stark represented
by the legendary Cregan Stark, but at this
point of the show, they are not yet main characters.
For Aegon it's his mother Alicent, grandfather
Otto and Ser Criston Cole, although there
are many more supporting him as well, namely
House Lannister who has their own man at King's
Landing court, Tyland Lannister, but they
are not the main characters.
This is when the war begins, but not war of
fire and blood, but war of ravens for now.
Let me also tell you that at this point of
the story, twenty dragons are alive, but the
majority will not be by the time this story
is over.
So as I said, Targaryen civil war begins towards
the end of season 1 when King Viserys dies.
His designated heir for many years had been
his only surviving child by his first wife,
his daughter Rhaenyra.
Since Viserys later remarried, however, and
had several younger children by his second
wife, Alicent Hightower, the eldest of which
is Aegon, half of the lords of the Seven Kingdoms
side with King's chosen heir and King's eldest
child, Rhaenyra, while the other half of Westeros
sides with King's eldest male son, Aegon.
The Seven Kingdoms had never had a Ruling
Queen before, and many were troubled by the
thought of Rhaenyra succeeding to the throne.
By the inheritance laws of the Andals, a younger
brother succeeds ahead of an elder daughter,
but the Targaryens had never formalized royal
inheritance laws for their new realm after
the War of Conquest 130 years before.
Viserys I, however, had extracted oaths of
fealty from the major lords of the realm that
Rhaenyra would succeed him.
Anyways, as soon as King Viserys dies, Queen
Alicent Hightower conceals Viserys's death
from the public and instead has Ser Criston
Cole, the Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
summon the small council to Alicent's apartments
in Maegor's Holdfast.
Criston who once served Rhaenyra, convinced
Viserys's son, Prince Aegon the Elder, to
claim the rule of the Seven Kingdoms as his
father lay dead.
For this he became known as Criston the Kingmaker.
Viserys had decreed his heir to be Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Princess of Dragonstone, the daughter
from his first wife, Aemma Arryn.
The greens at the Red Keep support Aegon the
Elder, the eldest son of his second wife Alicent,
however, and Criston takes into custody any
blacks remaining at court.
Alicent forbids septons and silent sisters
from treating Viserys's body.
A week after Viserys's death, his passing
is finally publicly revealed with the greens
accounting the accession of Aegon II Targaryen.
The silent sisters then prepared the late
king's body for the traditional burning of
a Targaryen.
At Dragonstone, Rhaenyrafinds out that her
father died and Aegon staged a coup and was
crowned King in King’s Landing.
She refuses to recognize the claim of Aegon,
her younger half-brother, and the blacks instead
support her as queen.
Rhaenyra, as Princess of Dragonstone, has
her powerbase on Dragonstone island, where
she responds by being crowned queen by Daemon
and declaring Aegon a traitor.
The rival claims to Viserys's inheritance
leads to the Dance of the Dragons, the civil
war between the blacks and the greens, the
very war in which most of the characters will
die along with their dragons.
Who’s claim do you support?
Aegon’s or Rhaenyra’s?
Who is your favorite character and which dragon
are you looking forward to see the most?
Thank you so much for watching.
If you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one.
Peace!